hi there steve kaufman here and uh today
i it's going to be a bit of a ramble i
warn you ahead of time
some semi-political uh opinions but i
want to talk about what is the best
accent to have the best form of a
language to have this comes up a lot it
comes up a lot with regard to french
portuguese spanish english
you know beijing mandarin versus other
forms of mandarin
you know kansai ben as opposed to the
more standard nhk japanese
and i'm sure it's true in a whole bunch
of other languages that i don't speak or
don't speak very well
and the reason i'm talking about it is
because
i follow this organization called the
canadian parents for french
i follow them because i'm interested in
french education in canada i think it's
important
that um
you know i like let's say i shouldn't
say that it's important but i like the
fact that canada is bilingual i like the
fact that more and more canadians
it isn't true that more and more
canadians speak french but i would like
to see more and more canadians speak
french i think they can do so without
the government spending
you know six seven hundred million
dollars a year on futile bloated
government programs
so i'm in favor of that but anyway i get
this questionnaire about language
insecurity and there's some kind of a
canadian strategy for language
insecurity and there's a whole bunch of
questions in this questionnaire about
whether i feel insecure using my french
in my family my place of work my this
that the other so then i look up
language and security on google and it
turns out that it has to do with
people who feel insecure about the way
they speak a language it may be because
they're insecure about their
uh you know
usage grammar it may be insecurity over
their accent it could be any number of
things that make people feel insecure in
using their language
now
and then one of the
reports that i read says that you know
there should be language should be a
safe space and all this stuff
to me all of this is quite silly
uh
in the case of a language that we learn
that's not our native language actually
we have a fair amount of freedom to
choose the accent that we like the best
and i find myself that if i'm in latin
america even though i'm used to speaking
spanish like spanish from spain with la
feta barcelona
down there i'll sometimes drop that
because
you know it might make them feel a
little bit i don't know i just feel a
bit self-conscious so i sometimes if i'm
speaking very quickly that
will be there and if not i might just
drop it
um
the same in in in i was in brazil so my
you know i get to it's more
uh sidaji for city now when we go to
portugal i'll probably drop that a
little bit uh when i lived in france if
i was in southern france for any length
of time i would sound more like a person
from southern france if i go to quebec
pretty soon i start to sound more like a
younger gua
we're more flexible in our native
language it's
it's more hardwired and therefore we
tend to stay with the accent that we
grew up with
um now
and also there are people who speak very
grammatically incorrect
english um
i traveled with a couple my wife and i
traveled with this couple and it was i
would have went i would have came
which are dramatically incorrect i don't
think they feel insecure
they just speak that way so um
you know i i think
you know it's a bit like okay if if you
are fat
uh or you uh
you know you have
white hair and you want to change it
there's a diet or you want a diet the
i.e
tea
to look thinner that makes you feel
better go for it if you don't like the
way you speak you can
by doing a lot of reading and listening
and focusing on it you could change it
or you simply say that's who i am and
that's good enough
but the idea that some government
organization and this parents for french
in canada is
massively subsidized by the
federal government you know if you have
an independent group parents for french
pooling their funds doing good stuff
that's great once they start going to
the government for funding
i lose interest in them and if they're
going to be part of a national strategy
to combat
linguistic insecurity that totally takes
me off because
there is no perfect world there is no
perfection and every attempt to impose
perfection
ends up
is basically
limiting people's freedom or limiting
their
need to take responsibility for
themselves
so
you know
is there a perfect form of chinese if
you want to sound like people from
beijing you just listen to a lot of
people from beijing if you are living in
taiwan and i know lots of people who
learned their chinese in taiwan they
will a be influenced by what they hear
around them and b they will probably be
less self-conscious speaking
with a taiwanese accent and it's
possible that they can flip back and
forth if they're on the mainland they
might feel self-conscious with the
taiwanese accent and they can either
live with that or
change it
so
there's no situation where you're always
going to feel secure
no government organization is going to
make you feel more secure you make
certain decisions i think insofar as the
best form of a language
to learn
you have less choice if you grew up
somewhere and you speak that way you
grew up in london or you grew up in
australia that's how you speak period
you're not likely to change it you
probably feel quite
comfortable and proud speaking that way
that's who you are if you don't like
having that persona you can change it
but if we're learning another language
then we pick the one that works for us i
don't think there's any objectively more
prestigious way
of speaking a language if you are
working and living in quebec you're
going to learn quebecois french
if you are working and living in
scotland i don't know if in scotland if
the real scottish brogue is more
prestigious than some kind of a
you know queen's english but whatever it
is you choose the one to imitate and you
do it and you don't need some
group to look into the causes of
linguistic insecurity sending out this
questionnaire which they obviously got
government funding for asking a bunch of
stupid questions
uh the bigger thing is
i think a lot of people
say anglophones who don't speak french
very well they feel insecure because
when they speak french say in the
workplace they don't
really speak the language well they
don't really understand what people are
saying they have trouble expressing
themselves they're going to feel
insecure there is only one solution for
that and that is to
improve your french in that case right
so
most of these situations are very much
in our control
don't require government funding
government programs and all the rest of
it and
uh i think it's just a matter of
choosing whatever
form of the language accent you consider
to be the most useful i mean if you're
in an environment where you're say
you're playing i don't know if you're
playing basketball and most of your
teammates are afro-american and and uh
you know you're an immigrant or not
you're a foreign player from poland you
may find that the most prestigious uh
form of english is that english that's
spoken by a lot of your teammates if in
fact they do speak the sort of whatever
they call it ebonics and stuff like that
however
by the same token an african-american
who grew up in an area where they spoke
the sort of ebonics
may find that a more standard form
uh
you know the more widespread on this
sort of within the united states form of
english might be more advantageous
uh in terms of academic opportunity or
professional opportunity
and then that person will make the
decision either to stay with what they
grew up with if that was in fact they
grew up with more of an ebonics type
um
you know english or they may move closer
to
uh the sort of standard form while
maintaining sort of some inflections
that reflect you know who they are
and typically that's what we see on
television when they have a you know
african-american commentators or or uh
you know
experts uh expounding on different
subjects so
all of this thing all of it this is to
say that do whatever you think is right
take the responsibility on yourself and
don't expect governments or
government-funded organizations to
impose solutions
thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]
you